depuis voilà presque un an bruno candida
des 12 coups de midi n'en finit pas de
faire parler de lui là vous avez fait
quand même les quatre saisons je vous
appelez le vivaldi des 12 coups de midi
en plus d'être un candidat exemplaires à
qui aucune réponse ne semble pouvoir
résister avec plus d'un million d'euros
de gains accumulés à ce jour il est
d'ores et déjà le plus grand champion de
l'histoire du jeu
[Musique]
tous
et si avec une telle somme remportée et
plus de 245 participation il est le plus
grand champion du jeu il est aussi en
termes de valeur de gain le plus grand
gagnant d'un jeu télé en france toutes
émissions confondues un parcours sans
faute ou presque car dans une interview
donnée par bruno au magazine télé poche
l'homme reconnaît une forme de
favoritisme à son égard de la part de la
production dans toutes les émissions à
champions il ya une mécanique qui
favorise il a ajouté également que dès
la première manche tous les candidats ne
sont pas soumis aux mêmes règles alors
que les nouveaux participants doivent
répondre à des questions basées sur des
sondages bruno explique les maîtres de
midi ont des questions de culture
générale lors de la première manche un
aveu assez rare mais qui s'explique en
effet pour ses émissions le fait d'avoir
chaque jour le même champion fidéliser
les téléspectateurs qui ont envie de
voir jusqu'où il ira une très forte pour
les audiences alors oui nos débuts
school midi avoue être avantagée par la
production choquée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que ce cas là je vous dirai ce
que j'en pense que j'ai fait des jeux en
fait ça s'explique très bien mais on va
en parler avec les mines et lopez ont
varié au moment où bruno gagne le
million l'émission quand même fait trois
millions de spectateurs à rennes pour
rappel il est me dire il est 20 heures
est-ce que bruno bpass
millions d'euros
les créateurs d'astérix se sont inspirés
pour le personnage de cléopâtre
[Musique]
brider sa [ __ ] aux encres battant dès
cet instant ces colons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
la personne
c'est parce que là je vais en boîte un
peu que le candidat reconnaît ce qui a
un du favoritisme pour le champion mais
c'est pas une surprise ça ne me choque
pas je vais commencer par la seconde qui
dit oui oui bah évidemment qu'on fait de
la télé évidemment que derrière toute
émission il ya un storytelling ya des
choses mais pardon quand on aime on
demande aux mecs qui en face de brüno où
se situe l'artère fémorale par rapport à
l'artère iliaque externe et lui de
chanter la danse des canards bah c'est
choquant je suis désolé il peut pas
quand bien même on voudrait fidéliser
les téléspectateurs on voudrait qu'ils
perdurent dans l' aventure on peut pas
avoir des questions de façon si
flagrante qui soit si facile pour bruno
c'est choquant je suis désolé il ya
plein d'argent je ne sais pas c'est pas
parce qu'il a des questions simples
qu'il va nécessairement pouvoir y
répondre
cette bouteille
de l'eau 10 ans
[Applaudissements]
la question clé moi la question sont
cléopâtre alors je vais vous dire la
vérité sur les jeux il faut savoir ce
qui se passe sur les jeux et ça n'est
possible que dans le pays et quelques
pays européens en amérique par exemple
suite à une énorme tricherie cas l'une a
eu dans les années 70 vous faites un jeu
télé à question vous devez avant le
début d'émission remettre un officier
toutes les questions qui ont opposé dans
la dans l'émission dans l'ordre etc et à
qui vous allez poser en france le
producteur peut envoyer des questions
qui veut il a dit ce qu'on appelle des
cartouches et avec ça peut être moyen
difficile très difficile poursuite et en
fait il choisit comment il va envoyer
c'est parfaitement connue à cette fois
je répète pas installer lormes mais
c'est vrai qu'à une gestion dans les
questions en fonction de l'état des
connaissances si vous avez un mec qui
est super bon en football bah évidemment
vous demandez pas qui a marqué un but à
la commune en 98 en finale par exemple
voilà
c'est que ça choque pas parce que le but
c'est de le divertissement ça reste du
business il faut faire de l'audience et
son côté comme ça chez moi c'est
fantastique comme l'économie télé
réalité les secondes de jeu qu'on voilà
maintenant alors le casting des jeux
avant et il ya des grosses agences à
paris qu'ils sont et geder vous avez
remarqué il ya les nier les mecs ils
font tous les jeux et financière un jour
tu gagnes le botanique jeter pour cent
briques ils font tous les jeux c'est
normal c'est de faire des jeux bien là
que dont s'était moqué des gens qui sont
connus pour ça mais aujourd'hui il ya
des recherches plus poussées parce que
tu crées passé notamment ce coup de midi
on enquête avec vue sur les candidats en
théorie non voilà mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'ils sont testés sur leurs
connaissances générales pour que le
producteur connaissent effectivement des
points forts et les points faibles et
fiona était insupportable
croyez moi qui connais rien au macramé
il était sûr que tf1 n'avait pas le
lâcher avant qu'il ne gagne le million
d'euros de gains sur normal ils veulent
fidéliser les téléspectateurs
ça se comprend tout à fait la patte du
producteur tu veux tirer un peu sur la
corde hier il a évoqué sa d'or non mais
est ce qu'on connaissait le top 3 des
des gagnants d'une taupe ou du des 12
coups de midi non alors y'a quesada donc
oui
alors il ya il ya ti et à bruno donc un
million neuf cent mille 407 euros de
gain d'une longue à 700 milliards de
cash quand même à le rester car il a
quatorze voitures 57 écrans télé
les espèces non ses mixes il ya eric 900
intérêt est toujours qu'il semble que
cela je pense que tf1 ils vont faire
griller beaucoup de gens pourquoi pour
que quesada d'histoire est
à mon avis à mon avis on va voir un
gagnant à 27 millions d'euros comme ça
ils ont été remis ni mondiaux alors est
ce que c'est un téléphone ou un
militaire